this episode of congratulations number
84 is brought to you by the cash app you
know the cash app it's the simplest way
to instantly send money to friends it's
also the number one happened finance but
it didn't get there on payments alone
these days cash app is changing how
people interact with their money it's
adding features you can only get from a
bank and more than a few that you can't
like the cash card boosts and Bitcoin
download the cash app for free on the
App Store or Google Play market now my
babies it's [ __ ] Labor Day it is Labor
Day and it is episode 84 it is Labor Day
and it is a besson 84 and is it 84
episode 84 because I started saying a
piece owed 84 but it's episode 84
because a pisode is not a word but it is
labor day and a lot of people take that
off because it's Labor Day but labor
means work some working I'm working on
Labor Day and I'm bringing this hot
podcast to you babies and you know if
you've been listening from the beginning
you're only over a little bit over 1
years old you're a baby that's over 1
years old and one year old I should say
1 year old not 1 years old because
that's 1 year old not 1 because it's not
plural but you know what we're starting
off this episode by saying lots of wrong
things and lots of wrong words and it's
because I almost had worms but it's
because my mind is going faster than my
mouth which is how everybody should be
because your mind if your mouth is going
quicker than your mind then you're an
ignoramus and I want you to know that
it's so anyway [ __ ] yeah dude it's it I
would say pretty much no I don't I don't
use this term a lot but I would say
pretty much it's it's [ __ ] it's lit
dude it's pretty lit man this week is
it's pretty lit man and that's all I got
to say dude it's pretty
because first of all I had a good time
this past weekend at the Comedy Store
and I did a show at the Laugh Factory -
danga - dang it you know I did a show at
the Laugh Factory dang it dang it they
did a show at the [ __ ] Comedy Store
dang it dang it it did another show at
The Comedy Store it and I'm gonna dang
it
oh and I did another show at The Comedy
Store dang it dang it and then I went to
the [ __ ] original and did a show there
dang it dang it I did lots of shows this
weekend and so that's it I put a clip
out of me of me rapping like Eminem and
it went viral and I'll tell you what is
very weird lots of people are like Oh
finally Chris D'Elia is getting the
recognition he deserves like that is the
[ __ ] thing like to it I got [ __ ]
[ __ ] I was on T I'm on you know I'd do
SH TV shows and I got Netflix stuff but
people don't like finally Chris puts a
video out and finally dude he's getting
the recognition he deserves hey if
that's the recognition I deserve gonna
jump out a plane without parachute but
no that's cool I'm glad people are
liking it like in it like in it I'm glad
people are liking it because you know he
came out with a pretty hot album is very
annoying people are like he's back like
you know you don't know you don't know
[ __ ] and then also people and then did
you hear the MGK diss that he made to
the he's a tall drink of water huh uh uh
you know I about these diss tracks that
rappers make and [ __ ] that uh that these
rappers make and [ __ ] and like it just
feels like the older you get and I mean
even older than like [ __ ] twenty it
just seems like what
it seems like it's like you're you're
hurt you know what I'm talking about it
seems like if you make a diss track like
you're you're hurt like you're upset and
you're whining to no older I get you
know but I don't know I mean I guess I
haven't because that's the thing like
the thing about this tracks is if
they're funny then that's cool but if
they're like yo I'm harder than you and
you suck like that then it's like what
like it's so it's almost like it's like
you're an adult though you know you're
rhyming hey man you're rhyming are you a
leprechaun hey dude are you a troll
under a bridge are you standing on wet
asphalt in the morning
no you're just a [ __ ] grown man with
a job and you're like and you're
basically like cars bars you know I mean
you're basically like [ __ ] a
hotel/motel that's basically what you're
doing you're a grown man and you're like
that guy [ __ ] piss me the [ __ ] off
you know what record this shoes blues
like that's like okay uh alright got you
bro hey dude oh [ __ ] that guy made me so
mad what he said about me check this out
hit record thumbs bombs like huh you're
a 30 ah dirty thirty you're like a
[ __ ] frat guy I don't know man
it's just hilarious to me but you know
hey dude whatever it works people eat
that [ __ ] up they eat that [ __ ] up for
Brax
it's [ __ ] driving dude how about this
[ __ ] so Beach
I mean dude hit him up that was it
there's a few [ __ ] quote-unquote diss
tracks whenever a white guy says dis it
seems so white and if a black guy says
it it's not but the dude to the one is
the Tupac one obviously hit him up
greatest of all time and then people
like the [ __ ] the jay-z one and the
NAS one that they were going with each
other and then I guess people like the
Drake one which I liked the back to back
back to back back to back um
those were good you know there's so much
we have increment that's how much we
haven't coming up on this mic when
you're on it doesn't mean coming so
anyway whatever oops
drop the app oh good so anyway that but
that's what's up but so that's what
happened in hip hop this week like I
should [ __ ] talk about that but
that's what happened in hip hop week
that's where you come to me for all your
hip hop news babies anyway somebody put
it under the mm thing that I did on
online somebody was cuz somebody tweeted
it and they didn't tag me which is fine
I don't give a [ __ ] about that but
somebody wrote at first I thought it was
Chris D'Elia and then and then I wrote I
wonder why you thought that and then and
then the person wrote are you actually
trying to insinuate that this is you and
I wrote wait what
like huh yeah somebody wrote dude it's
weird how many people say that I look
like Andrew Lincoln and I don't look
like Andrew Lincoln I don't like when
all it takes for somebody to have a
beard and long hair and somebody will
say that they look like another guy with
a beard and long hair that's so annoying
to me people caught my least-favorite
tags are hey look Chris found you're
working at Target and it's just some
[ __ ] slob with some long hair and
beard they don't look like [ __ ] me I
don't look like them
uh wait I gotta go out of this um so
yeah anyway I did my [ __ ] live [ __ ]
on my app if you want to catch that you
can [ __ ] go on that and do all that
dude have you guys heard about this
[ __ ] I mean here's that here's how I
know I'm an old guy IIIi don't know
about this I didn't know about ASMR
until recently now a lot of you guys who
listen to my podcast I'm not gonna know
it as some are as I know because a lot
of you guys are adults and a lot of you
guys are younger and do know what a ASMR
is okay I didn't know what it was
but it's this [ __ ] thing where they
YouTube these these people YouTube is
usually like young girls that do it
which it's which definitely it's
definitely this first okay ASMR is like
well okay here's the definition
autonomous sensory meridian response is
an experience characterized by a static
like or tingling sensation on the skin
that typically begins on the scalp and
moves down the back the neck and the
upper spine I mean [ __ ] who wrote
this Trina it has been compared with
auditory tactical sin I mean sis sin
Nastia oh yeah [ __ ] this [ __ ] [ __ ] these
words anyway low-grade euphoria a
combination of positive positive
feelings and a distinct static like
tingling sensation on the skin
alright look so people will make these
video you these youtubes and they'll
just like be like
redhead that's getting me and all this
is like [ __ ] nine years old and she's
like and then a car will drive by in the
background it should be like and she
tries to make her lips like so it's
gross as [ __ ] to be honest like I don't
to hear that I'll just spit in your
mouth they're just like and then they'll
eat the gummies and Rigo like and people
like jizz to it or something but they'll
be like they call them triggers what's
their scalp to tingle they'll be like
and and then he'll be like this and then
they'll just scratch they'll be like
this and then a car will drive by oh
should be like and then they'll be like
like don't like what what are the
popular is some are triggers though one
of them is like [ __ ] now there was a
bob was watching a video of it the other
day and it was like but like it's here's
the thing
it's [ __ ] definitely there's that
top-10 triggers for a samar that's the
one I was looking at know the by the
fourth one like the fifth one or
whatever and it's like the tapping
listen to this [ __ ] I got a I got a
[ __ ] play some of this actually on
this YouTube it's weird and here's the
thing - this is the thing that I want I
want it to bring it up this is the thing
I wanted to bring up by the way is that
if you're listening to this and you're
[ __ ] you're a guy it's you can't fool
us that it's not sexual you perv okay
don't watch these [ __ ] look at this
yet what they say here we go here I just
don't understand old guy but these ASMR
close-up ear to ear positive
affirmations for anxiety and sleep like
this she's fluttering her hands you hear
all the spit in her mouth
no you're not you're whispering she's
talking about dude she's talking about
like helping people and like making sure
that they're like in good not I guess
not depressed or some [ __ ] and like take
care of yourself in your well-being but
and she's doing the whisper thing the
whole time she's like hey say it louder
hey is it important say it louder
look at how how many views I mean I'm
the [ __ ] wrong one here - like five
hundred and seventy seven thousand views
ah oh how many of those are old dudes
getting [ __ ] boners for real
straight-up
you're getting boners bro you can't fool
me that it's about making the top of
your scalp tingle it's about making your
boner go up you know it's it's [ __ ]
weird to me I get uncomfortable when I
watch ASMR [ __ ] man makes me
uncomfortable I don't give a [ __ ]
obviously but there is a [ __ ] fan
base for everything like the internet
like take take the mm and MGK dish now
there's way too many people being like
nm is the best don't [ __ ] with him and
in his way too many people be like MGK
came as [ __ ] fire though and then
after and then a bunch of people be like
MGK oh that was ridiculous that was
horrible and then hey remember when like
things used to be like unanimously good
remember like in like the 90s
u2 was just amazing you know and now
people are like the internet brought the
haters out dude
it's amazing dude it's really amazing
because like here's the thing - when
we're talking about like everyone
complaining and [ __ ] about everything
most people aren't happy with what they
have that's just how it is
okay so therefore most of those people
not everyone but most of those people
are going to complain okay so that's a
lot of people who are just complaining
now the Internet is now very big
everyone has it so most of what you're
going to hear is complaining therefore
we have no choice but to become a world
full of hating [ __ ] that's what's up
now I'm joking about this ASMR [ __ ] like
if you like it you like it fine but like
and I'm turning to this this is turned
into a different point and then it is
kind of devolved as this podcast usually
does just devolve into [ __ ] nothing
but yeah it that it's just that's that's
that's that's what is [ __ ] up about
this world and the internet and we're
all going to become a bunch of huge
[ __ ] and we haven't even seen the
beginning of it yet
we are going to become huge [ __ ] and
then something else has to happen and I
don't know what it is yet I don't know
what it is yet maybe we're going to be
what do you call it
a bunch of we're gonna be a bunch of
them what do you call it uh it's gonna
be a pulse and pocketable get up explode
the world's gonna [ __ ] kill it we're
all gonna kill us others gonna be
[ __ ] a third of the population left
as you me like one of those [ __ ]
Netflix movies that extinction movie
we're all gonna [ __ ] die and there's
only gonna be a few left and it's all
gonna be because the [ __ ] MGK Eminem
and ASMR and [ __ ] like that and people
hating on the internet mm-hmm I don't
know that barely makes any sense but
this is what you get you know let's talk
about why the [ __ ] every time every time
I see [ __ ] I follow Mark Wahlberg on
Instagram every time I see Mark Wahlberg
on Instagram it's a [ __ ] new video
about how he woke up earlier every
single time I have [ __ ] it started
that like you know you know you don't
want to burn daylight right you got it
you can't pretend like right you got to
wake up I'll wake up at 7:00 a.m. and I
get working out I wake up at 7:00 m/m
a.m. and I carry kettlebells I carry
kettlebells from one end to the other of
the of my gym and I got a [ __ ]
workout got buddy and he makes me carry
my kettlebells from one end to the other
and then [ __ ] the next like three
days a ders I kind of wake up at 6:00
a.m.
gotta wake up at 6:00 a.m. and you gotta
push this [ __ ] thing that football
guys push and you got to put the weights
on it and I gotta push it from one end
to the other that's what I got to do and
I got to get my trainer to sit on it too
he's taking a video it's fine to be
better get up at 7:00 a.m. and then four
days later gotta wake up at 6 a.m.
what I got to do is that kind of got a
curl I got to curl these two things I
got a curl these these these dumbbells
and I got a [ __ ] and I got a do a
bunch of chin-ups I got to do it again
because people are waking up at 7:00
a.m. because I was waking up at 7 a.m.
and then people started to come to me
wake up at 7 a.m. and now I gotta wake
up at 6 a.m.
cuz I gotta wake up earlier than them
cuz I gotta get I gotta get successful
get more successful native and then five
days later guys woke up to 5:00 a.m.
welcome
five a.m. and I'm basically building
sandcastles I got a bunch of dumbbells
but I put them to the side I have my
trainer bring a bunch of sand in here
it's really good for my my my small
muscles inside my big muscles and its
really good for my my striations no
building sandcastles people are waking
up at 7:00 a.m. because they copy me
well I'm looking up it's 6 p.m. and 5
a.m. now and then he started this thing
a week later I got a 4:00 a.m. Club I
woke up before I get him welcome before
I am and not only do we build in sand
castles but we'll also doing is we're
making them water will put a water in
the sand council so now we'll build an
even bigger sandcastle wanna make sure
they we're gonna get some paper mache
tomorrow waking up at 3 a.m. my question
for Mark Wahlberg is when do you go to
bed I mean are you like are you like the
rest of us and you go to bed at 11:30
p.m. and do you get 30 minutes of sleep
or do you go to bed at 7 p.m. I sort of
got in one of his Instagram videos he
was like went to bed at 8 o'clock last
night
hey dude what are you doing you're going
to bed earlier than the news you don't
even know what happened in the daytime
I'm missing everything but at least I'm
moving at least I'm creating sandcastles
I didn't hear what dan Rather had to say
I don't know who shot anybody but I'm
building sandcastles I'm a gym like what
when are you going to bed went to bed at
5 p.m. last night
what did winter bed before dinner I ate
lunch went to bed so funny dude
Mark Wahlberg is also one of those guys
that no matter how uninsured
he's been no matter how out of shape he
got he's been in shape most of his life
that he just looked SC jacked no matter
what like it all goes to his chest I
woke up at 8 p.m. the first of the day
before
hey everybody I woke up at 8 p.m. the
day before when you go to bed I went to
bed after that but miraculously I woke
up earlier than that what I'm going back
in time every time I call him bad I go
back in time and I wake up earlier than
when I went to bed the [ __ ] me only guy
who does it aspire to be better I wake
up before I go to sleep huh and he's
just so ripped no it's just so jacked
the more literally read because you see
his muscles like a red and white like
it's a skeletal [ __ ] diagram hey Mark
Wahlberg you can even see his lips his
just [ __ ] skit skeleton you see his
tendons just moving aspire to be better
I'm building sandcastles on a skeletal
dude it's so [ __ ] weird five for
clothing guy take my pad I had to wake
up before I went to bed so I could take
my protein somebody wrote on his [ __ ]
Instagram I think why the paper plate
and the paper and the paper forks hey
man choose your battles you know Mark
Wahlberg's not gonna respond to you
because of recycling he's busy
waking up at [ __ ] 9 p.m. the day
before he went to sleep dude I [ __ ]
Mark Wahlberg is so [ __ ] dope that's
so funny but hey you know what Mark
Wahlberg's doing ASMR when he talks hey
guys the top that's goin just want to
talk to you about some new iSmart rageth
and that's building sandcastles let's
move this sand around shhh castle doing
some ASMR feel the vibrations feel the
vibrations at the sand castle makin Shh
let's tap a little bit let's get the
Funky Bunch over how to tap a little bit
woke up the [ __ ] what I am got a
whisper because my wife's asleep
to some scratchin scratching on
kettlebells if your thoughts vibrations
defueling sensations the sensations that
beer scalp contact with the Funky Bunch
feeling this is inflation dude Mark
Wahlberg's voice was built for ASMR
that's how ASMR started they've heard
Mark Wahlberg talking at 4:00 a.m.
because his wife is asleep and they were
like some kid was like wait a minute
let's tap in a car drives my room
what is this world coming to the
Internet's [ __ ] everything up I'm
sweaty dude I'm so sweaty can't get no
air vents in studio no air vents in the
studio not bad but there should have
been air vents in the studio I want to
stop I don't know dude I'm up alright
look good we're gonna do these here
hey post mates as usual your stomach and
the rest of your life are at war you
need to eat but you can't stop what
you're doing to deal with it because you
on the go and the only fast things that
deliver are not what you want because
that's the world that we used to live in
but now the world we live in has post
mates this is the app that adds a
delivery option to your favorite
restaurants imagine anything you want to
eat delivered you don't have to drive
park or even talk on the phone to order
you download the app and order 24 hours
a day 365 days a year
posts mates will bring you bring what
you want within the hour you can even
see where your food is and track your
driver
I do it every single day
no joke you forgot to get eggs and milk
no problem craving a tasty burger check
looking for the perfect bottle of red
wine or a summer beer order up post
mates is your new long-term munchies
booty call for a limited time post mates
is giving you $100 of free delivery
credit for your first 7 days to start
your free deliveries download the app
today and use code Congrats
that's code congrats for $100 of free
delivery credit for your first 7 days
save the hassle get the food you love
fast at post mates with the code
Congrats guys
I want to talk to you about this thing I
just signed up on stitch fix and I am
excited to receive my first box signing
up was very easy ah and honestly I look
forward to what theirs what they're
gonna send me stitch fix is an online
personal styling service that finds and
delivers clothes shoes and accessories
to fit your body budget and lifestyle
you don't need to be rich to do this
just go to stitch fix calm / Congrats
and tell them your sizes what styles you
like and how much you want to spend on
each item you'll be paired with your
very own personal stylist who will
handpicked 5 items to send right to your
door then you try them on pay only for
what you love and return the rest
shipping exchanges and returns are
always free
are you not stylish then you have to do
this there's no subscription required
you can sign up to receive scheduled
shipments or get your fix whenever you
want stitch fixes styling fee is only
$20 which is applied toward anything you
keep from your shipment so that's cool
get started now at Stitch fixed calm /
Congrats and you'll get an extra 25% off
when you keep all five items in your box
that stitch fixed calm / congrats to get
started today stitch fix dot-com /
Congrats guys
Square cash the cash app you know the
cash of its a simplest way to instantly
send money to friends it's also the
number one happened finance the cash
card is a free customizable debt card
that you can use at stores or ATMs it's
linked to your cash app balance
as if it were a checking account it even
lets you direct deposit your paycheck if
you're looking for an alternative to
traditional banking you're not alone
millions of Americans have already
started using the cash card have you
tried the boost the the rewards program
have boost get instant discounts every
single time you swipe your cash card at
coffee shops Chipotle Shake Shack and
beyond just tap a boost in the app and
pay with your cash card cash app is also
the most convenient and inexpensive way
to buy sell them withdraw a Bitcoin and
the coin is the hot thing right now and
of course when you download the cash app
and enter rewards code Congrats
five dollars goes to you and five
dollars goes to time's up Legal Defense
Fund download the cash app for free on
the App Store or Google Play market this
podcast has a very good cult following
and you guys are my babies and you guys
understand that sometimes these podcasts
they look these podcasts are like life
these podcasts are like the days you
live in your life some of them are going
to be a hot [ __ ] you're gonna wake up
and you're gonna [ __ ] feel it right
away right and you're gonna be living
your day the way it [ __ ] goes and the
way it should go and the way you imagine
it right and that's great and you listen
to these podcasts and thank you for it
some of these podcasts are gonna have
ups and downs just like life sometimes
I'm gonna get on a [ __ ] run talking
about [ __ ] like how Mark Wahlberg wakes
up before he goes to sleep and that's
gonna be funny sometimes I'm gonna talk
about ASMR and do a [ __ ] silly little
thing that you're gonna [ __ ] like like
way back when when I did the [ __ ] how
robots are taking over the world and how
everyone's going to be outed out of a
job that was like episode six and
sometimes I'm gonna be rambling because
the Moran blood man
and it's gonna be [ __ ] yeah I'm gonna
lose you that and and look I'm in a
corner in my [ __ ] podcast room and
this is what it is I got my orange chair
that already had I set it up I
videotaped it because some you said you
wanted to see me do it and this is what
it is dude have at it
if you don't like it don't listen I
don't want you to [ __ ] listen I want
the people that are going to be in my
cult [ __ ] sitting pretty with me at
the log cabin eventually and you
understand that this podcast is like
life my babies you're gonna have good
days and bad days and if you don't want
to be a part of it gonk gonk dude dude
how dumb is good gunk Wow
I [ __ ] suck donkey balls you know I
[ __ ] suck donkey balls man I'm just
doing this [ __ ] every week cuz you keep
[ __ ] listening and you keep asking me
to I don't know man
people started [ __ ] giving me money
to do it now I got sponsors I gotta
[ __ ] keep doing it you think I give a
[ __ ] I don't know man
I just want to do stand-up and [ __ ]
talk to you [ __ ] I just want to
tweet dumb [ __ ] and do silly [ __ ] on my
Instagram I know I got this [ __ ]
goddamn podcast I got to do every week
and I have to do it cuz now I make
[ __ ] too much money doing it for
[ __ ] sake how's that for something to
complain about I [ __ ] do my whole
life to try and not have a boss I do
stand-up and I do this [ __ ] I want to do
so I don't have a boss I turned down
[ __ ] TV shows
cuz I'm happy I got this [ __ ]
stand-up [ __ ] that I got to do and I
don't want to have to be employed by a
company that's gonna be like hey you
can't say this or tweet that or careful
who you text what and what they
screenshot [ __ ] no I don't want
to do that I want to smart context who I
want to touch how I wanna text
I want to say what I want to say how I
want to say it and I don't want to
[ __ ] have to adhere to your [ __ ]
and now I got this goddamn podcast that
I got to do every [ __ ] week cuz you
guys pay attention to it [ __ ] you man
and you know what in a jolly way [ __ ]
you in the most fat jolly way dude
picture me the fattest guy eating
McDonald's happy as [ __ ] watching my
kids play in a park while I'm sitting on
a bench just saying with a big
shit-eating grin from one end to the
other [ __ ] you [ __ ] you for listening
now I gotta do this [ __ ] every goddamn
week every goddamn week I gotta do this
[ __ ] because it makes too much money
well whatever bro
thank you thank the [ __ ] you man thank
you man
thank you and I mean it from the bottom
of my Bulls I mean it from the bottom of
my [ __ ] hairy nuts dude how about
people who shave their [ __ ] balls and
Knutson taint and their [ __ ] pubes
what the [ __ ] are you doing dude what
are you doing
you swimmer no you're not and even if
you are you've got something that covers
it like a speedo
dude that's gangster if you were a
speedo that's gangster is [ __ ] I'm
wearing Speedos for now on forever I
have a speedo by the way and one time I
went to my beach house my parents beach
house they don't have it anymore they
got rid of it but they just have a beach
house and one time I came down to my
speedos and my mom was like no
Christopher you go back upstairs and you
change and I was like what mom they do
it in France and she was like you are
not she's like I can see the side of
your balls and I was like that's how
speeders are designed dude and I went
out to the [ __ ] ocean and dude we
were in America and they didn't like it
my mom didn't like it I'm hairy dude you
could see my pubes a little bit if I
wear a speedo so sue me that's not my
fault that's the people this meters
makers fault don't get a beach house
don't invite me to your beach house if
you don't want to see the [ __ ] hair
on my thighs because I'm speed owed the
[ __ ] out and I don't cross my legs not
what no I don't cross my legs guess what
I don't cross my legs unless I feel like
it and I don't feel like it sometimes
when I'm wearing Speedos
it's like that whole [ __ ] pack [ __ ]
camp episode man I think about that all
the time now when I go to the gym I'm
[ __ ] walking around in trance around
naked and my [ __ ] gym and I've and I
think about it now I think about it when
people when guys are like ah [ __ ] and
they look at me at the gym I'm like [ __ ]
man or what if they heard my podcast and
then I get a little bit insecure but I
still try to keep the eye contact man
not cuz I'm gay and I want to suck em
but because this is how it is the gym
this is how it is in the [ __ ] locker
room I show my [ __ ] in the locker room
and if they make speedos I'm gonna get a
speedo do you know why do it because
when I get in the ocean and when I get
in the pool I swear to god - I want to
be aerodynamic as [ __ ] I want to be
aerodynamic as [ __ ] dude and it's
because not even because I want to swim
fast or whatever first of all if I'm
going in the ocean let me tell you right
now dude if you go in the ocean past
your knees you're [ __ ] crazy dude
you're crazy
if you go into the ocean and the and the
water is coming up above your knees dude
you're crazy you know what percentage we
know about what's in the ocean one one
goddamn percent you're gonna go waist
deep into the unknown hey man who are
you [ __ ] Buzz Aldrin you're in if you
go into the ocean above your knees guess
what your name is now [ __ ] Buzz
Aldrin or the other guy how about the
other guy that got the raw end of the
deal who's he
Buzz Aldrin I'm asking Neil Armstrong
dude Buzz Aldrin had the dopest [ __ ]
they both went Neil Armstrong as a more
famous one [ __ ] that dude
Aldrin had the dope name here's the
thing here's the thing now here's the
thing dude they think that I'm [ __ ]
like yeah Neil Armstrong is the [ __ ]
most famous guy okay
okay I get that he got the raw end of
the deal when it came to stepping out
onto the moon like the guy went first or
something what happened Neil Armstrong
went pert first and Buzz Aldrin Buzz
Aldrin was like hey what about me but
let me tell you who the [ __ ] real man
was Buzz Aldrin because his name is Buzz
Aldrin that's like that's like saying
you know when Neil Armstrong was like
we're going to the moon and Buzz Aldrin
is like I'm going to you know the other
arm so I was like well I got to be the
[ __ ] first guy to get out there
because this [ __ ] [ __ ] name is
Buzz Aldrin if I'm the second guy that
goes imagine the first guy that went on
to the moon
imagine the [ __ ] imagine the [ __ ] you
if you step on the moon dude and you
were the first guy on the moon and your
name is Buzz Aldrin the [ __ ] you to the
universe Neil Armstrong Neil art as a
matter of fact I bet they I don't care
what the government says I guarantee you
Buzz Aldrin was the first guy that that
they got that was like I can do it on
the most qualified and then they were
like well we gotta find the [ __ ] guy
in NASA or whatever that had the most
that has the best name and then they
were like there's one guy and they're
like who and they were like Neil
Armstrong and they were like well we
have to have him and we got him they
were like look Neil we can't let Buzz
Aldrin take that first step if they do I
swear to god we don't know that there's
aliens but we will know because they're
going to [ __ ] take over Earth and
explode on us because his name's Buzz
Aldrin and that's the biggest [ __ ] you
that'd be like if your name was [ __ ]
moose McGillicuddy and you were just
like and you're just like oh go and
you're like here we go
moose McGillicuddy one small step for a
man one giant leap for mankind
moose McGillicuddy the first American to
step on the moon foghorn
horn mumun unit with the [ __ ] Moon
Unit Zappa
or whatever the [ __ ] his name is like
you gotta have [ __ ] Neil Armstrong if
you're gonna have Buzz Aldrin you can't
have [ __ ] Buzz Aldrin and then
[ __ ] moose McGillicuddy you know the
Russians would be like we've gotta level
them that we will kill them that's
hilarious dude I don't give a [ __ ] Neil
Armstrong got the raw into the deal
because of the name and I know that Buzz
Aldrin got the wrong end of the deal
because Neil Armstrong how about this
dude let me tell you - that's a boss
[ __ ] move what Buzz Aldrin did that
is a boss move dude I guarantee you Buzz
Aldrin was the most Tupac [ __ ]
of all time because his name was Buzz
Aldrin he went to the moon and he let
Neil Armstrong take the first step on
the goddamn moon bro when I'm driving to
do a show three hours away and I'm with
my openers I want to [ __ ] step into
the am/pm before them and that's how
[ __ ] I am and Buzz Aldrin was like go
ahead Neil and his name was Buzz Aldrin
that's some gangster [ __ ] dude that's
what Neil Armstrong was that's what
[ __ ] Neil Armstrong was like this I
get to take the first step this is
amazing I get to take the first step
this is amazing
this is amazing I get to pick the first
step this is Neil Armstrong you're gonna
let me do that Buzz Aldrin
this is [ __ ] amazing and then and
then he did it and then Buzz Aldrin
[ __ ] step behind him and was like it
didn't yield the Armstrong died or no is
he dead
who's dead Buzz Aldrin and Neil
Armstrong who died buzz is alive in Neil
Armstrong died then then when Buzz when
Buzz is alive in Neil Armstrong I'm Neil
Armstrong died [ __ ] Buzz Aldrin was
like this Buzz Aldrin still alive dude
thinking about the moon like guess when
Buzz Aldrin died dude [ __ ] when Neil
Armstrong died Buzz Aldrin was like this
dude I [ __ ] suck do you know what I
mean I [ __ ] suck this is awesome dude
I'm dripping sweat let's face facts guys
I can't lie to you I gotta be [ __ ] a
hundred percent honest with you guys
that's for ask I'm trippin [ __ ] sweat
when I'm after this I'm gonna take this
shirt off I'll tell you what I'm gonna
do right now just to be [ __ ]
disrespectful on your [ __ ] I'm
gonna order goddamn food I'm gonna order
post mates that's what I'm gonna do I
wouldn't get rid of post mates no one
fire no mates dude that's it guys gettin
post mates being real disruptive on you
[ __ ] you know why because I can
and you're gonna listen anyway do it I
love getting post mate oh it's close the
place I want to go is close cool pissed
how about places oh yeah cuz it's Labor
Day bro
[ __ ] Labor Day not [ __ ] Labor Day I
guess it's good
every [ __ ] every uh yeah delivery
dude okay let's go
every um holiday in Canada they have
like once a month they every other week
is like Monday is off I didn't know that
did you know that I didn't know that
until I did but that's usually how
things work
I won't roast here's all I'm gonna do
see this is when I order for this [ __ ] I
get the [ __ ] I get the grilled salmon
see that's how we do it to it okay I
don't want that there we go
ordering I thank you for listening while
I'm ordering you guys that's it and now
tender greens doesn't [ __ ] clothes on
and a tender greens they don't clothes
on on Labor Day because they know what's
up how about in Italy though they take
off all of August
ah what if you want a sandwich I mean
you know hey if you go to Italy don't go
in August
imagine [ __ ] saving up you got to
spend [ __ ] 12 grand for you and your
family go to Italy and you go August 2nd
to August 19th hey can I get some help
sorry we all are offer we're not going
back to work until September first go
[ __ ] yourself
hey do you know where I can get a
sandwich sure Paris not here what is it
look what googling right now does Italy
shut down in August TripAdvisor
does it say not to go
I wonder dude tourist stuff
sure is open cuz it's the summer it's
gotta be but dude if you live in how
about [ __ ] that man
imagine imagine having a whole month
where everyone's off I would be
infuriated I would be so angry if that
happened I would hate that some a whole
month dude dude they're just sitting
around [ __ ] getting [ __ ] eating
the pizza that they made all year
they're getting so many [ __ ] it's a
[ __ ] month Farrah Gaston is a public
holiday celebrated on the 15th August in
Italy to see you know it's so foreign to
say 15th August and not August 15th and
San Marino it coincides with the major
Catholic feast of some of the Assumption
of Mary the [ __ ] I'm meta name a metonym
I met an Amy I don't know what the [ __ ]
my name is a figure of speech in which a
thing are up click on it again one fire
concept referred to by the name of
something closely associated with that
thing because oh yes a confusing dude ok
so here's what they said Metin Amy met
and I'm I and this is the definition is
a figure of speech in which a thing or
concept is referred to by the name of
something closely associated with that
thing or concept so just wrong that's
just wrong it's a summer vacation period
around mid-august which may be a long
weekend Pompeii they've had a ghost
though or most of August most of all or
most of August I mean so general the
whole thing it's something that we
thought was something but it's not
something but it's closely related to
something and they take off either
August 15th or that weekend or all of
August ok
hey Wikipedia get your [ __ ] together and
it who wrote you know who runs that
Italians they don't give a [ __ ]
sorry we posted you need it we posted
about it in August we weren't really
working we wrote it down and we didn't
do a research so so we just know it's
around the August we think it's August
15th but also it may be the weekend or
all over August just write it down I
will figure it
in September and it's September this our
lazy they are at September [ __ ] third
and they already did and they still
don't do it it's a Labor Day in America
though so [ __ ] it will await Attila
September a fourth and even not in
August they take siestas they're [ __ ]
you can't get dude if you try to go get
take the [ __ ] some [ __ ] to the
drycleaners don't do it at 12:30 or
13:30 whatever the [ __ ] they call it
you're [ __ ]
they're out there are getting [ __ ]
BJ's dude that's what they are
remember second a class of citizen
female I'm a common home at 1:30 but at
13:30 p.m. to get my cookin together my
balls are drained I'll be back to get
your dry cleaning at the [ __ ] 15:30
after my balls drained then they come
back tired of [ __ ] hey sorry so tired
slept sat down on a comfy couch to go to
my balls rain and then the passed out
did you need your did you need to get it
you suit chuckling for what huh you only
work five hours a day what do you need a
suit for what do you need that for for I
just get your balls ring it's for gusto
it's August on on unreal dude Italy
[ __ ] I want to I want to Italy with
my family and my dad thought he was
Italian
I mean he's Italian but he kept on
trying to [ __ ] he kept on like my
dad's the kind of guy who goes on a trip
that's like and now let's you let's
[ __ ] talk how they talk you know and
I'll be like we'll be at a restaurant
and they'll be a little bit like he was
asking for cheese he kept on asking for
one kid so unki a so and then he found
out that it meant [ __ ] little church
he was asking for a little church he was
asking
for [ __ ] little church to put on his
pasta and everyone was like I know what
he's trying to say nobody corrected him
until the end he was like I know what
he's trying to say okay cool yeah bring
him cheese
hey the [ __ ] [ __ ] Americans ask
him for a little church from Maggio she
saw you saying like chase or some [ __ ]
whatever little churches that's
hilarious
but whatever my dad was trying to say it
was like what is he trying to say and
then the maitre d was finally like a
little Church was so funny but one time
too I was going we were going we were in
Rome and we were trying to go to [ __ ]
meeting the whole family my dad and my
brother and my mom and my dude what also
too when we were before we were going
my brother dressed up in his regular
clothes and then I dressed up in like a
shirt that was like a little bit lime
green and I had these Rose tinted
glasses like some [ __ ] [ __ ] like I
was a like of us Lance Bass or some [ __ ]
you know when you're 20 you do some dumb
I was 19 I was a teenager I'd look like
a [ __ ] [ __ ] right and but I
remember I was like working out real
hard at that time and like I had a
[ __ ] that shirt on that was like
showing off my [ __ ] Cascade and
[ __ ] double black diamond [ __ ]
amount of [ __ ] then and my brother
showed up to my parents hotel room and
my brother my dad was like hey Matt you
look nice and he said I Chris you look
funky and we [ __ ] use it the whole
time cuz he we're like Oh hates it so
much but he had to say funky kiss me cuz
i know cuz you look cuz we're gonna say
it anyway he was good like Oh Matt you
look nice and he was gonna say Oh cuz
you look and then he saw me it was like
you look funky such a dis such as subtle
slam didn't even realize it and that's
why you got the current slam master
right now man that's the origin story
but anyway we went but anyway yeah
everyone has an art historian that's
mine so we went to [ __ ] eat and the
guy who was the hostess or the host even
though he was a guy he was almost as a
female job so uh sexist whatever anyway
he was like 60 whatever I don't give a
[ __ ] it's a comedy podcast and and so we
got there and
and we got there and the guy and the guy
with my parents were like going and get
a seat
my dad was probably outside trying to
[ __ ] do something real Italian like
smoke and eat a baguette and paint on an
easel and he was like go get a seat and
and I was waiting for the guy in them
and the host guy was like singing and I
always Oh
this became like a big joke in my family
but like he was singing and he was
whatever was saying was like lots of
Italy like s Italian whatever he was
doing lob C don't move and then he
[ __ ] looked over at me just with his
eyes and he saw me there and I caught
him singing and I was trying to act like
it was cool like I don't give a [ __ ] he
was singing and then he just goes Bulge
ordinal and every time I bring that up
my aunt [ __ ] laughed so hard she goes
do the thing in Italy when he when he
caught the guy singing and I'll just be
like D I'm gonna look at him I said my
eyes now say buongiorno that's what it
was and it was so funny dude and I was
19 and I looked funky and he looked at
me and he was like that guy looks funky
anyone Bongiorno anyway that my dad
asked for a little church on his food
american do we have questions only a
couple well that's fine
let's do a want to do the elder we got
another elder elder dude we've got
another elder baby look at an elder
because you guys now let me just remind
you guys these elders take our word we
take they take our cult they take our
you know they either tell people to turn
around because they're doing something
wrong or they help spread the word by
creating things like art and music and
whatever the [ __ ] it is that helps
people hear and learn and and also about
this cult and then also kind of just
enhance our experience as cult members
so this elder is now this new newest
elder congratulations to Brett Bergstrom
at scrip games scri PGA M yes now I want
you to congratulate him on Twitter he
made a game called Okuda and it's pretty
cool game where you get to be a little
pacifier and you come out of a log cabin
and you shoot other pacifiers to kill
these Kudus they're good is all I know
they're kouddous dude because I can see
their Kudus and it's very [ __ ] cool
so it's like what will flood it because
it's a pacifier you know you shoot other
pacifiers out of the pacifier yeah
you shoot pacifiers out of the pacifiers
and you hit Kudus and you get three lies
lives and it's like that game one of
those old games probably a game called
asteroid or something anyway so do we
have any questions as to questions we
met a true baby in the wild for the
first time last night that is a phrase
that's a phrase we created on this
podcast if you spot a true baby in the
wild you take a picture if they're
wearing a CUDA shirt an Okuda shirt or a
[ __ ] daliyah's grants grants time
shirt we made a true baby in the wild
for the first time last night we were
talking about merch and someone leaned
over and said did you just say one fire
the next couple of minutes were full of
gunk and turn around Krista Leah brings
people together
congratulations pot thanks Melissa
Ramirez for your testimonial
miss miss wipe ler thank you very much
change it but thank you very much very
cool that you spread the word and you
come together I love when babies come
together man I really do if you have if
you're in your city meet up with other
babies if you don't know them introduce
yourself
share ideas live the hedonistic
lifestyle meetup if you're a male baby
and a female baby or if you're a male
baby in a male baby or if you're a
female baby in a female baby meetup [ __ ]
and suck each other make each other come
because we share ideas and we live the
hedonist hedonistic lifestyle meet up
with other babies as friends meet up
with other babies for [ __ ] and
sucking for drennan balls
you know for rocking the flat fried
butterfly that's how we do it Chris
D'Elia from JT cure at cure JT how do
you feel about people riding unicycles
in the year 2018 kick their [ __ ]
wheel out from under them make them
scrape their knees that's not something
we do anymore if you're riding a
unicycle get attention in other ways
have a goddamn personality right and I'm
not talking about one of those big-ass
wheels that it's [ __ ] I don't want
the [ __ ] ones that are so big were
you like how the [ __ ] did they even get
up on there if you need friends to help
you get on a unicycle if you got one of
those little bitch-ass ones though let
me tell you something if you have one of
those little bitch-ass ones those little
ones where you just kind of like you're
a [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] look at these
pictures of unicycle look at these
[ __ ] this guy's in the wheel on this
one what an [ __ ] like he's like he
thinks he's a LAN musk yeah if you have
a unicycle and you're just [ __ ]
riding through New York City with a hat
on if you have a unicycle on if you if
you're wearing if you're on a unicycle
there's like a 95% chance you have a
goddamn hat on I've never seen someone
on a unicycle with not a funky hat on
right uh yo djenka s-- at yo genka sh yo
I heard you love Persian men I mean sure
man
you know what okay yeah I do I guess I'd
like I like him like I like other guys
too I have a [ __ ] Persian I have a
bunch of Persian friends one of them's
my best friend are you trying to get
like I [ __ ] him and sock him I don't do
that but just because that's not my
preference that's all that's all the
questions we got you guys came up with
some [ __ ] lame as [ __ ] questions I
mean two of them are okay
one of
wasn't a question the other one was
about a unicycle that was the good one
and then some guy just said I heard you
love Persian men okay hey men okay so
look you guys thank you I had a great
time this episode it began a little
clunky but boy that second half was hot
[ __ ] just like life is sometimes
remember guys keep Berber in and
download the cat download the cash app
for free on the App Store or Google Play
market and two rewards code Congrats get
five dollars give five dollars - times
up download my app in the App Store
Chris D'Elia just type that in and and
you can look at the first few minutes
live on that on the podcast and you can
see it before anyone else sees it and
you can be the envy of all the other
babies merch available go to Chris
D'Elia calm and you can also buy tickets
to my follow the leader tour I'm going
to a bunch of places coming up subscribe
to our You Tube channel rate and review
the show on iTunes and all that [ __ ]
where if you can't video episodes go up
on Tuesdays and Wednesdays and watch
everything a mom okay and if you have a
unicycle make sure and [ __ ] fall down
and scrape the goddamn knees thanks bye
[Music]